soft robots are robots that exploit
their compliance to be
highly adaptable and be able to deal
with the environment that are not
structured highly dynamics and they can
provide
also a safe human robot interaction
despite these fantastic advantages
they still rely for their control on
electronics and so microcontrollers and
also some of them can be also controlled
by pneumatic actuation uh so
limiting a little bit the usability so
today so you can see actually here uh
several examples of uh soft robots we
mainly use to fabricate these additive
manufacturing so multi-material 3d
printing so we can actually make them
several characteristics in terms of
mechanical properties of the material
and here you can see actually what it
takes to control this system and for
example like uh we need a lot of valves
that of course cannot be embodied to
avoid that they can impair their
movement and also their compliance
adaptability so today i will show you
how we are going to solve a little bit
this issue towards
what we call soft matter computing in
particular what we want is to achieve in
future
electrical free electronic free
soft controllers that can be embodied in
in the robot body and also can perform
computation so we don't need to rely in
future to
electronic microcontroller and and
valves uh in particular what we are
doing is uh to
3d print these kind of
systems such that in future they can
actually be manufactured together with
the robot body and have a highly
integrated solution we usually use this
multi material 3d printer
to print the valves and so we can we are
able to
actually
3d print the the valve with
the different mechanical properties of
the material the one for
the soft membrane the bi-stable membrane
and also the the spool
and thanks to this so we can actually be
able to manufacture this uh
so is that more than one head printhead
or is it just use the same printhead
this is a polyget printer so he has many
heads and they use acrylic-based
polymers that are released as a drop and
there is a row that actually pass
through it with a uv light for the
curing so that is the way in which this
is different from maybe
fdm uh 3d printers so these allow to
achieve very high accuracy and that's
the reason why we can use it also to
make
soft robots with the like empty chamber
thanks to the accuracy of the printer we
can print so many valves all together in
one batch without the tray and after the
printer can
like perform all the manufacturing for
us usually what we do at the end of the
print we put the parts that are like
covered with the supporting material in
a chemical bath so for uh that will
dissolve the supporting material so
providing us with the final part that we
can assemble
today we show that sr latch that is one
of the basic element of computation with
a soft bulb so sr latch i think you
probably already saw the videos on
computer files about latches so you can
actually go there to to check their
functioning with a d flip flop we can
store a single bit of information
we design a manufacturer a soft bulb
that can actually functionally replicate
the similar behavior of an sr latch what
we do is use a bi-stable membrane to
actually switch state between one and
zero and this bistable membrane is also
connected to a spool valve that allow to
actually
get the output that will be connected to
the soft actuator that you see here so
the energy supplies of the whole system
comes from the compressor here which is
basically a pneumatic reservoir which
provides us the energy however how we
distribute energy to the robots depends
on the state of these memories so by
resetting and setting the state of each
valve which refers to each bit of binary
information what we can achieve is to
differently distribute the predator
process the information and activate the
software the left-hand side the number
one valve we are showing here is the
bi-stable structure we use to
store the information
and in order to convert that information
into the pneumatic signal we use to
control this arm what we do is for the
second one here we attach a spool valve
on it
so that we can convert that information
into the configuration of this robot for
example now if i send a set signal
what we can see is that the robot will
be activated
and if now i reset it
the robot will restore to its
equilibrium position where do you see
these sort of robots as being used okay
so soft robots can be used like in
general they have been considered idle
effectively for example for manipulation
of soft produces for example in
agriculture or like in the the food
industry that's because they are like
very compliant they don't require a very
complicated control and the knowledge of
the model of the object because they can
actually
like adapt to it and be able to grasp so
this is actually tree jaw gripper by
controlling it with even in open loop is
able to grasp object with different
shapes and that is actually something
that have been considered very um
advantages for for like
in general for this kind of manipulation
application but also you can see here a
soft arm and you can imagine when you
want for example to do pipe inspection
or you want to navigate in environment
that are really cluttered so you want to
be able to dexterously
navigate through the environment and
reach something so like the rigid robot
again require a lot of
control because when they navigate this
kind of environment you don't want to
damage the environment or the robot
itself or maybe like have a not safe
interaction with humans while because of
their compliance this soft robot can
actually achieve a
very dexterous configuration and
also they are safe so they can
be in contact with the environment and
without like damaging it and you know
the kind of soft vowels and things
you've been obviously talking this
through do you think they were scaled
down will they be scary that is actually
the next stage of the research because
at the moment we achieve that kind of
science but to be able in future to
of course uh
embed that kind of system in the robot
body and perform some computation we
need to be able to to scale down that of
course require some technological
advancement from the additional
factoring point of view materials so
soft robotics actually need a lot of
inputs from other disciplines to be able
to to progress further because it's
effectively yeah like you need it to
work in like biology right yeah i mean
there is a cellular size here very small
yeah exactly we need to definitely try
to achieve like a very immune material
is a software to be able to build a
logic gate and uh and actually perform
computation in future
there you go so here we have different
quadro pads today we're gonna see the
spot one yeah just to give an idea of
where we traveled
this is all the way from where we were
before here with the
round table